let's talk about a really good remedy
for tartar now what is tartar tartar is
dental plaque what we're really talking
about is something called biofilms okay
and biofilms are
a combination
of these calcium
houses that house
bacteria it's one of their survival
mechanisms what they do is they hide
underneath this calcium little dome and
that way they go undetected from your
immune system as well as from
antibiotics in fact 95 of bacteria in
nature
live in biofilms
if you even take a look at a like a
little rock in a little stream
and if you actually pick that rock up
you'll notice it's a little bit slimy
and slippery
that's biofilms
so biofilms are all over the place it's
some survival mechanism that's been
going on a very very long time so
anytime you have water as in saliva
you're going to have biofilms and if
there's an overabundance of biofilms
you're going to get bad breath you'll
have
issues with inflammation receding gums
and of course many people get to the
point where it's too much and they're
going to have to go to the dentist and
have it extracted but what i want to
talk about is if you are continually
getting too much tartar in your teeth um
i'm going to show you what to do to
prevent it or manage it a lot better now
a couple things i want to mention
xylitol the sugar alcohol as in the
xylitol gum and xylitol sweeteners have
anti-biofilm properties they help
suppress adhesions to your teeth so if
you're going to chew gum make sure it's
xylitol and there's also natural things
that are
anti-biofilm okay natural herbs you have
rosemary
you have clove
thyme oregano oil
garlic curcumin which is in turmeric
cinnamon
and another compound called nac
all of those can help reduce biofilms
however the remedy that i want to talk
about really has just three simple
ingredients okay and i'm going to tell
you why you should use this the number
one ingredient is baking soda now why
baking soda baking soda is sodium
bicarbonate okay
so one thing about biofilms especially
the ones that overgrow around your teeth
as
tartar can start producing too many
acids and when the ph gets to the point
where it's like 3.5 to
5.5 then the body starts leaching
calcium out of your bones it's called
decalcification and so it's very very
important to make sure your ph in your
mouth does not get that acid you want it
neutral or maybe slightly acid but not
too much and the real main thing that
produces too much acid is what i talked
about in another video
it's the
sugar it's your diet if you're consuming
too much sugar or you're diabetic you're
basically feeding the exact food that
these bacteria love as well as the yeast
because there's also a type of yeast
called candida in biofilms as well and
as they eat all this sugar they produce
the byproduct of lactic acid and now the
ph starts to decrease and the
environment starts to become ideal for
extracting calcium from the teeth so
you're getting cavities and then of
course the microbes are using the
calcium for housing
so using baking soda sodium bicarbonate
is a great way to
increase the ph to make things a little
bit more alkaline to help buffer that ph
so the acid isn't there anymore to leach
out calcium also baking soda can help to
break down these biofilms and the other
thing that's very interesting about
sodium bicarbonate baking soda is that
this is what your saliva makes to buffer
these acids so you're just taking
something that your body is already
making so therefore it has virtually no
side effects so you'd want to mix one
fourth of a teaspoon
in a half of a cup of water okay then
you're going to add one more thing and
that is called hydrogen peroxide now
you'd want to make sure you get the
three percent hydrogen peroxide
and you can get from the drugstore but
hydrogen peroxide is a really good um
compound to help inhibit
biofilms from developing as well as
killing off bacteria
yeast candida
all these microbes and another very
interesting thing about hydrogen
peroxide is guess what your body makes
it it's in your saliva hydrogen peroxide
is a major
compound that your cells use to kill
microbes so we're just going to give
your body what it naturally produces but
it just in higher quantities so you use
a fourth of a teaspoon of baking soda
and a fourth of a teaspoon of hydrogen
peroxide three percent
mix that in a half a cup of water and
then use your toothbrush to brush your
teeth after you brush your teeth with
toothpaste what this will do it will
help prevent the biofilms from
continuing to come back and that way
your teeth will be nice and smooth now
one last thing there is some interesting
research it's a little bit mixed but
there seems to be a positive correlation
between
vitamin k2 and inhibiting this dental
plaque so some people who actually start
taking vitamin k2 that normally comes
with vitamin d3
starts noticing that the inside of their
teeth are becoming smoother and smoother
so that's another little thing that you
can you can try but in general vitamin
k2 is all about
transporting calcium into the bone and
out of the soft tissues but anyway i
wanted to give you a really good simple
remedy to prevent
tartar from building up in your teeth
and i think another good video for you
to watch is more information on vitamin
k2 check it out i put it right here
you